we got to get to one of my favorite
dudes because he's the director of hard
knocks on HBO their on-site director for
a third season matt dis injure it is the
Tampa Bay Bucs this year Matt it's Ross
Tucker filling in for Dan here on the
Dan Patrick show I'm doing great man
first question did the Bucs volunteer
for this or were they picked they were
picked we selected them this year you
know obviously when we talk to these
teams we try to get a measure of you
know the level of cooperation that we
think will get here and the Bucks have
been very cooperative so ever since we
started talking them they've been open
to the idea and just went down you know
had the press conference there on
Wednesday and everyone with the
organization was pretty great so does
that mean that no one volunteered to do
it this year
yeah we didn't have a volunteer this
year okay so then we have those
different qualifications now where you
guys get to pick out of that group so
there's I don't know how many teams
there are and then you you decide who
the three or four most interesting teams
might be and then have conversations
with them as to what kind of access you
get or how willing they be to do it
before you make your selection yeah it's
something like that I mean it's above my
pay grade you know I'm the director of
the show but those conversations kind of
happened that like an ownership level
and a upper management level here at NFL
Films but the way I understand it is you
know we put a feeler out to all the
teams you know it doesn't have to be one
of the teams in that list and then you
know based on those conversations you
know however they may happen we kind of
move forward from that point when we you
know get an idea whether someone might
have some interest or at least be you
know willing to cooperate and we go from
there
don't you have to be involved on some
level Matt just because I mean you know
your bosses and the owners don't yet
this doesn't boss say all right we got
three or four teams to pick from Matt
which one you think would make the best
show has the best storylines know for
sure I mean we have conversations but
you know it's not like someone's coming
to me saying all right who do you guys
want to do this year you know so you
know we'll talk about it we'll kind of
discuss why we think you know it's he
might be attractive and you know why we
might want to pursue them you know in
those conversations you know I think
influence
how that decision is made okay so then
why bucks sell me on why you guys picked
the bucks and why I should watch the
show you know I think you look at that
roster there's not a lot of more
charismatic quarterbacks and Jameis
Winston I think that stood out to me
from the beginning I'm not sure that
we've had you know you know a
quarterback on hard knocks before that's
had that level of success you know that
level of charisma I mean you know being
here at NFL Films we wire I don't know
four to five players and coaches every
single week you know I remember his wire
from last year of the dozens and dozens
and dozens we've done and it really
stood out to me and you go down the
roster you know Mike Evans obviously
they shine signed to Sean Jackson in the
offseason you know we've done a lot of
work with Gerald McCoy in the past we
know how good he is you know we worked
with you know Dirk cutter and Mike Smith
in Atlanta those guys are great with us
there so there's a lot of positives for
us you know I think this is a team to
that's successful you know they're 1970
right in the verge of the playoffs it's
going to be fun to see you know how
winner is put together and how they
mature and take that next step that's
something that's attracted to us you
know for hard knocks
how does it work Matt with you deciding
which players kind of want to feature
for the show and Mike up and have
cameras travel and then do you kind of
have to ask those guys hey we'd like to
have you be one of the featured guys
like the cush guy with all the
sleeveless shirts last year that guy
were some how do you how do you approach
those guys about being one of the
featured characters it's funny it's a
it's you know a long process it starts
kind of soon after you know the team's
announced will go through and research
you know we have a team of myself my
assistant director Shannon Fuhrman and
then I have three field producers and
we'll all sit down and we'll look at the
roster and we'll assign like alright you
do running backs you know you do
offensive lineman and we're going
through we're looking at you know
whatever videos online of these guys and
we come up with a plan now you take that
plan you might go in and say alright we
have these 40 to 50 guys and within the
first week half of them you know go out
the window and then another 20 30 dudes
you didn't even think about show up and
you're like wow this guy's pretty
interesting and the really the thing
with hard knocks honestly is you know
the best laid plans you show up and you
might think you know what you're going
to do but you little batter
what happens so when you get there on
the ground that's when you really have
to have your eyes and ears open and
characters you know cush was kind of on
our periphery last year it wasn't like
we walked in saying he's going to be a
star but obviously he I think you know
was cooperative
we found him to be really funny I think
the audience liked them a lot so it's
just a matter of being able to you know
read and react once you get down there
in the field talking with Matt dissing
sure he's the director of hard knocks on
HBO here on the Dan Patrick show how
often do as a coach or a GM or somebody
ask you to turn the camera off or maybe
even a player if it's a really tough
moment for them I mean there's been
times I think where we know someone
needs a little bit of privacy but what
we really operate on and what we say is
like look we know there might be stuff
maybe it's personnel discussions or
whatever like but we have let us film it
see how we're going to present it you
know we're not in the business of making
anyone look bad you know we're NFL Films
you know we're here to promote the game
and promote the teams so anything we do
you know we do with that in our minds
you know we we have ously have a
relationship with the Buccaneers like we
do the other 31 teams and we ask that
hey let's just see what we're going to
be up to and you know make that decision
later we're sensitive to what they're
sensitive to and most of the times the
things are sensitive about we're not
really interested in in terms of you
know things we put on air you know X's
and O's stuff has been something that
we've been the primary focus you know
last thing on earth whatever once for
someone to do hard knocks and for them
to have a competitive disadvantage
because of that so we're always looking
out for that kind of stuff but then
again our audience I don't know that
they're really looking to hear what play
calls you know the Buccaneers are going
to do I think the most in these you know
human interest stories which is what I
think we pride ourselves on a last one I
have for you Matt is I think one thing I
would hear people say is man I've seen
the rookie get cut now a million times
I've seen the one rookie make the team
how do you keep it fresh
you know it's something I get asked a
lot and I think the answer to that is
look at training campus training camp
you know you know it can be very
monotonous it could be boring but every
year every team has a different set of
personalities it is only one Jameis
Winston there's only one Mike Evans
there's only one Eric cush from last
year or Austin Hill and yeah all the
beats all the beats are going to be the
same it's a training camp but I think
the personalities and the guys you get
to know they present you with a
different story I think you understand
what it says stake and every year it's
something different who knows maybe it's
a guy that's been the league for 10
years and maybe it's make-or-break time
for you know his twilight of his career
and then maybe it's the guy that was
undrafted three years ago and it's his
last shot you know every year it's a
different set of circumstances and it's
a different set of characters and I
think the best way to confront the how
do we make this fresh is like well
that's fine the most interesting guys in
this team and let's get to know them as
best as we can
Matt really appreciate the time thanks
so much and looking forward to the show
when's the first day well the first
episode airs August 8th it's a Tuesday
we're on the ground starting in late
July they're you know about a week
before training camp opens up for them
Matt thanks so much thank you guys
there is Matt disinterred the director
of hard knocks on HBO I still remember
my rookie year watching the first ever
hard knocks
it was Malta more Raven coming off the
Superbowl Siragusa shannon shannon
sharpe Billick they cut they brought
they signed and cut Tim Hasselbeck they
had that quarterback from Arizona Ortiz
Jenkins that was just terrible really
should Randall Cunningham now fell on
the league so for me though I was a
rookie living it at the time so I was
watching it to see what it was like when
guys got cut and stuff I watched every
second of every episode that first year
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience